hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well towards the end
of nikuman Canon ethics book 10
Aristotle famously suggests that the
next work that one ought to look at is
his work the politics which has to do
with political science the reason why he
suggests that is because there's a
connection between political communities
and ethics and education education for
Aristotle takes place in a much broader
way than we typically conceive of we
associate it with academics we
associated with schools with
institutions that we explicitly identify
as educational for Aristotle the family
and the community also provide important
measures of Education not only for
citizens but for the children that are
brought up within that community as well
now much of what he has to say about
this is coming towards the end of the
book 10 that's everything down here
there is something that he says early on
in book 10 which i think is very
important to bring out and think about
before we go into that and this has to
do with the relationship between
pleasures and activities something that
we've done several other videos
specifically about going into much
greater detail so pleasures and
activities reinforce each other what we
mean by that is what we enjoy we get
better at because we do it more often
because we enjoy something because we
take pleasure we're willing to put more
time into it Aristotle uses the example
of somebody who really enjoys music
they're willing to put in the time to
say practice an instrument and because
of that they improve as musicians and
they learn more about that topic on the
way which has against or the
self-reinforcing in fact because they're
better at it it is more pleasurable so
what we enjoy we get better at by
viewing and what we what we are already
good at we enjoy we get something out of
it and so there is this you know sort of
self reinforcing dynamic that way that
can also be problematic in other
respects because what we don't enjoy we
probably don't want to put too much time
into and we won't get good at and if we
understand virtue that is moral
excellence and something similar to that
kind of knowledge that's involved in
knowing how to do something
understanding how to apply general
principles or techniques within given
circumstances then it's going to be
important that we actually enjoy what we
do now for a while and we're when we're
working our way towards virtue its kind
of take it to the mania you don't really
enjoy it you're being self controlled by
privilege in reason or your practical
rationality over what it is that your
desires are doing and so sometimes it
can be painful to act in virtuous ways
even though you choose to do that
because you recognize that is it good
but over time through repetition it
becomes as Aristotle says second nature
there's implications for this for Vice
as well bias can be sent
nature just as much as virtue can't so
by doing the wrong sort of things over
and over again you come to enjoy those
sorts of things you know by being greedy
you learn by acting greedy how to get
away with it and what sort of things to
do and what sort of things not to do and
it becomes part of your mindset so this
is a very important aspect of Education
even the virtues and vices in the habits
and jelmo that we need to attend to
Aristotle also said something very
interesting and this applies to his own
work he tells us that discourses on
ethics are not by themselves
sufficient to make somebody better what
does that mean well for example simply
watching videos about people you know
talking about aerosols theory and virtue
or epictetus azure Plato's or anybody
else you like or watching videos in
which people act well towards other
people and make us feel kind of warm and
fuzzy inside Curtin there so that
doesn't do anything for us unless we've
already got something established
already he thinks that it makes us maybe
feel good and that's a bit seductive we
we think that we're doing better than we
actually are
now what he has to say about this is is
not that it's bad to read you know books
of that Thanks
but really it's not sufficient to make
people better so what is missing there
what is lacking here some is this
metaphor he says that the soul the soil
that soul look that's what it actually
is here but the soil must be tilled in
order to receive the sea so when you're
when you're firming right or when you're
planting your garden first you're gonna
plow up the ground now I know that today
we actually have no qualms where they
just inject it directly into the ground
that's not the way it was for most
agriculture throughout almost all of
human history and we may get away from
that as well we tear up the ground and
then we can
plant the deceit so you need a garden
that doesn't already have weeds noxious
vices planted in a bad and habits you
need something that will give you room
in which you can work so what does he
mean by that good habits he says that
good habits in fact lead us to act and
think in good ways more naturally when
we have the kinds of habits that we need
and we need them Aristotle thinks
already being established as children we
need to be inculcated in certain basic
approaches to say right and wrong or
what's fair or how to be generous we
need to have praise and blame assigned
to certain things Aristotle would say
that you know as opposed to many people
who think that moral norms should be
kept out of education he thinks that
they absolutely belong there because
children need them in order for that
soil to be tilled this also includes
feeling pleasure and pain in the right
ways we need to feel pleasure and pain
on the right occasion for the right
reasons
and not for the wrong reasons so and
when people can tell they want to bring
us up right if people can tell that
we're feeling pleasure at the wrong
sorts of things they can recommend us
they can encourage us to do something
different they can structure activities
in such a way as to promote a different
balance of pleasures and pains now over
time this will as Aristotle says produce
a sort of natural affinity for virtue
that's what this till the soil really is
a natural affinity for virtue for loving
what is Noble and so if that happens
then the field has been plowed and then
the teaching can actually do something
lasting that Aristotle says you're not
going to do much with a book of ethics
because the people who are bad and
aren't gonna listen to you
anyway you maybe you could enforce you
know certain norms by punishing them but
that by itself doesn't actually make
them good that just keeps them from
doing worse things may but otherwise do
right the other thing that he says
that's particularly interesting and
relevant here is that nurturing
education should be handled by two
things one is by law by Nomos by what it
is that the political community itself
decides upon in an organization this
might be you know sort of the basic
rules right or he says laughing that who
else can provide this sort of education
in that case it has to be the parents or
the family now in our situation we might
think of other intermediate institutions
that could perhaps step in when the
political community is falling down on
the job it's worth noting too that
Aristotle in book 10 says that pretty
much all of the political communities
except for Sparta have done a terrible
job with this and Sparta has done a not
quite terrible job so he's not happy
with any of these he thinks that
appearance friends people like that have
to try to help other people to develop
virtue those who they're connected with
those who they're charged with and how
do they need they do this he mentions
three sort of things that they attend to
one is what we might translate as rules
no my right or normally sorry this can
be translated as laws it can also be
translated as customs these are sort of
the foundational norms that we work with
and those he talks about in a political
community and in a polis but it could
also apply the family discourse lowboy
actually explaining things to people
this doesn't mean that you just you know
let anything fly so long somebody can
make an argument but there has to be a
cultivation of the mind involved you
can't just come down hard on people with
pretty much mint or you know reward or
even crazy
you need to tell them why what they're
doing is good or bad at least to the
degree that they're able of taking it on
then finally there's the this
ever-important dimension habits of ethic
ethics means habit means something that
has developed through activities over
and over and over again that's why this
dynamic that we pointed out at the start
is very important we want to make sure
that if you want people to be good you
have to have them doing good actions so
that they can actually eventually get
some pleasure out of it and they can
stick you want to steer them away from
the sorts of bad actions that will
almost you know naturally in a bad
environment begin to develop bad habits
for them because they take pleasures and
the wrong things so ethics and education
very closely connected for Aristotle but
education like I said understood in a
much broader sense